hey guys in case you missed it here's
our favorite set from our new special
the roast of Captain America enjoy
there's language thank you for hosting
tonight Iron Man you're doing a great
job
I love how mean your jokes are because
it makes me feel less guilty about
killing your parents
I'm kidding I do not feel guilty Natasha
what are you even doing here your only
power is being kind of okay at shooting
people I can't wait for the next move
when you try to do that head scissor
thing to Thanos and he just throws you
into the Sun seriously look at this dais
of idiots
no wonder Dead pull out grossed every
one of us dream journal furnace stone
wall freight car these are not my
trigger words I'm just listing things
that are more interesting to look at
than Batman V Superman that was the
first movie I saw after three years of
cryogenic stasis and I still fell asleep
I wish Lex Luthor's goons had killed
your mom it's just she seems like a nice
lady and doesn't deserve to be stuck in
these films
also I'm a sucker for mom killing hey
Tony Superman I've never seen a
franchise hate fun as much as yours does
and I have literally never smiled
Suicide Squad was supposed to be funny
like guardians of the galaxy but it got
about as many laps as 12 years of slave
red skulls confused by that joke because
that was his favorite comedy of the year
you dumb Nazi how are you going to say
you're part of the master race and then
get beat by a Rubik's Cube you look like
someone dipped the tip of their dick and
hot cheeto dust
Hulk is here guys the Hulk is a
legitimately mentally ill person you
wouldn't like me when I'm angry is not a
superhero catchphrase it's the
background noise on a 9-1-1 domestic
abuse call
black panthers here too Black Panther is
a trailblazer though he's the first
black character to get his own movie in
the MCU he's also the first and only
superhero whose costume includes puka
shells
I have no transition to get division I'm
not actually saying that I'm just
quoting Joss Whedon script notes for age
of Ultron vision there was literally no
point to you other than to remind people
that we added a robot to the team before
we add in an Asian person but let's talk
about the man of the hour
my best friend Steve Rogers let him hear
it
now a lot of people tonight have liked a
joke about how we're bot buddies and we
probably bang each other all the time so
let's clear that up right now of course
we do I let this man plow me like a
snowdrift blocking an emergency-room are
you kidding me look at this man he's
like a Greek god wrapped himself in an
American flag and then covered himself
in baby oil he has muscles a human being
should not have sir did you guys see
when Steve came out of that super
soldier machine my [ __ ] got so big we
had to put purple shorts on it if you
saw that scene and you didn't get hard
you're lying to yourself it it just
means your penis doesn't work okay it's
not even a sexual thing it's just your
dick acknowledging the alpha male in the
room I'm not ashamed of it sexuality is
a spectrum and mine is somewhere between
straight and I went bobbing for plums
and Steve's ass last week would you like
to know more
steve has opened my [ __ ] so much Thor
can use it as a portal to Asgard my anus
has been stretched further than Robert
Downey jr. x' disney contract i don't
know if there are any supervillain still
trying to unlock the secrets to dr. s
cons formula but I have so much
super-soldier DNA inside of me that I
might be a national security risk Steve
I love you and I want you inside of me
and I am wow just now realizing that
this is probably a conversation that you
and I should have had one-on-one and in
private I apologize I Love You Man give
it up for Captain America you guys [ __ ]
was a joke cringe and right was a cringy
people keep saying was cringing I said
his tripod was amazing round of applause
Jewish guy from Winter Soldier
thank you if you like watching me
fulfill my lifelong dream of flirting a
lot with Casper Van Dien as much as I
enjoy doing it you can watch the whole
roast uncensored uncut on screen junkies
plus and if you register now you can see
it for free and we want to bring you
guys like a bunch more of these roasts
so tell us in the comments below what
character you want to see us roast next
cuz we want to do a lot more of these
but we want to know who you want to see
get the kind of treatment that Joe just
gave cap I think it'd be cool to get
Deadpool oh that kind of like I got one
Reynolds to actually roast people pretty
crazy
hey this video should add yella quick
video so it gets popular we'll get right
Reynolds to do a roast of Deadpool no
pressure Ryan but if you want to like
call us what am i doing to this video it
feels really dirty it's covered up by a
box right oh I'm fingering a box that's
even worse cringe